- [Mark] Look at you.
You look like a movie star.
- [Reilly] (laughs)
- [Mark] Okay, Reilly.
You have another story for me.
- [Reilly] I do (laughs).
- [Mark] Tell me about it.
- [Reilly] Somebody
must've told you about it,
I'll have to bring it up from my memory.
I was young, I was really young.
And I just started prostituting,
and I used to dress to the nines.
Anyway, this man picks me up,
and its a little sports car,
he's a big guy,
he's a white guy.
And we're driving,
and the next thing you know I wake up.
I'd fallen asleep.
So when I was younger I used
to fall asleep all the time
because I'd be out for days,
and I'd fall asleep.
Luckily I wasn't talking to Saint Peter,
but that might've been better.
I sat up,
I didn't know where I was.
And I see this like, fences,
like you know with (laughs)
like with a board and two posts,
and I look to my right, and there's this
metal kind of fence.
And there's cows,
and I'm thinking, "What the fuck".
And all of a sudden I
look a little closer,
and the man that brought me there
is out there with a pair
of boots on butt naked
up by this cow,
and he's rubbing... I guess it was poop.
It was poop I remember.
And he was jacking off,
and I thought, "Oh my god I'm
gonna get killed by this guy".
This guys out here (laughs)
I mean what kind of person
starts jacking off by cows.
I don't know.
- [Mark] Do you have
any idea where you are?
- [Reilly] I was out in cow
dairy country or something,
you know out by, I
don't even remember now,
maybe like Chino or some place like that.
- [Mark] Somewhere outside of LA?
- [Reilly] Oh yeah, out of LA,
I fell asleep for quite a while.
And, he just.
You know I've survived all these years...
- [Mark] It's night time or it's day time?
- [Reilly] It's night time.
I've survived all these
years because I'm pretty good
with my, you know,
I'm not psychic but, you know, I.
I'm empathic, I can feels things,
and something told me, "Get up and run".
You know (laughs).
And I'm not really kind
of a paranoid person,
but when my body's running before my
brain tells me to do it,
you know I gotta go.
So I get up and I start running down this,
it's like a wall, of not hay,
but like straw, and it's I don't know,
probably 15 feet high.
And its just like this road,
yellow brick road, it's yellow
wall road, down the side.
And I start running down this thing,
and I don't think he's gonna sneak on.
So I'm running, I'm running,
I'm running, I'm running,
and all of a sudden I see the
car lights come down the path.
(gasps)
So, what I did I tripped and I fell,
and I didn't notice it when I was running,
'cause it was like an optical illusion.
There's like a wall, and then it stops.
There's a gap, but
there's straw behind it.
So it looks like it's there but its not,
and so I kinda fell through it.
And I was like (gasps).
Then I see there was a
farmhouse with lights on.
So I start running and running,
its part of this whole
compound or something,
started running and I
think, "Oh wait wait wait!"
Maybe there's a whole bunch
of, a whole fucking family
of these weirdos,
that are gonna cut me up,
and you know what I mean,
and mess with my feces, I don't know.
I go no, no, no, can't do that.
And something tells me,
I see ahead of the fence to get out,
and there's a big chain
around with a lock on it.
And I was like,
(whispers) I can get out somehow.
I have to get back to the car.
So I went back out I go,
"Oh, I didn't know where
I was when I first woke up
I didn't know where I was,
and so I was scared, I
just took off running
I didn't know what to do".
- You told him this?
I told him this.
You know, I've gotta get back in the car,
I didn't want him to think
I was scared of him, right.
So he gets back in the car,
and he's looking at me,
hes kind of like looking me up and down,
trying to judge what I'm
thinking or whatever.
So I said, I said, "Sorry I fell asleep".
I said, you know,
"We can go ahead and do what
you want to do if you want to".
There's this man that's
got feces all over him,
and he's "oh, I just gotta
go one place else before
I take you back".
And I'm thinking, "One more place..."
That's my coffin (laughs).
So we're driving on this road,
and this doesn't have like
sidewalks or streetlights.
It's just like road, and a little
dirt incline, little dirt incline.
And there's like,
agriculture, cows, whatever.
And it's pitch black,
and I'm thinking,
(whispers) "Oh my god".
And all of a sudden I see a street light,
this isn't like a street light,
its like two big cables that
are hanging across like this
with this thing hanging in the middle,
that's the stop light like
two roads are crossing.
But I see a car coming our direction,
and so we're getting closer,
we're getting closer.
I can't just scream, you know.
So I just grab the steering wheel,
right into this guy.
Drove right into him.
Not bad, just (smack) we hit him.
And so he gets out, the
guy gets out of the car
and he starts screaming at him.
I get out of the car, I start running.
I don't know why, but I
start running down this road.
I gotta get away, he might
kill this guy and get me too.
I don't know, but I'm gonna
take me out of the factor.
So I'm running down this road, right.
- [Mark] How fast were you going?
- [Reilly] How fast was I running?
- [Mark] How fast were the cars going?
- [Reilly] It was just one car,
me and him, our car and his car.
- [Mark] Yeah, but how...
- [Reilly] Oh, I see, probably 40.
- [Mark] Wow.
- [Reilly] I don't know, I
wasn't even thinking about speed,
it was just stop and have somebody
else as a witness over there.
You know, when somebody's
trying to kill a guy,
I just wanted somebody else there,
so I could take off running (laughs).
He was a big guy, this other guy
wasn't going to be able to do anything.
So I took off running,
and I ran and I ran and I ran and I ran,
and I saw headlights coming
so I ran off the road and I heaved,
and there was another car, wasn't his.
So I kept walking and the
sun started to come up.
And I knew I shouldn't
have gone that route,
with dirt road, gravelly
dirt and smells like...
I could cut the cow urine with a knife.
You know like pates,
and so I'm dressed to the nines.
I am dressed like I could
go anywhere right now.
I mean I could go to the
Academy Awards, (laughs)
- [Mark] Oh God.
- [Reilly] I could go anywhere (laughs).
So I'm walking down this road,
and I'm thinking "Fuck,
what am I gonna do?"
I don't have any money,
I don't have anything.
- [Mark] What shoes are you wearing?
- [Reilly] I'm wearing stilettos.
- [Mark] Oh Jesus!
- [Reilly] But back in those days
I could run track in stilettos, you know.
So I'm like, "Fuck".
So, trucks started going by,
these pickup trucks,
with these farm workers.
They were like, (hollers).
They're screaming at me, woo-woo.
So I thought I'd get some
ace (makes whooshing sound)
I wave, right (laughs).
That was when I was like 19, 20 years old.
I was like bam bam bam bam.
Everything was just,
butt sitting up here, you
know, everything was just.
So I just give them my little "Help!",
and they pulled over.
Now, I never have, never did before,
and probably will never again.
Turning dates like this,
but they just pull the pickup truck over.
Now, there's nowhere to hide,
its just like fields with
stuff growing, and more fields.
And stretch with nothing around,
nothing, no, nothing to hide behind.
And they just opened u
the pickup truck doors,
(laughs) I go in the
middle and I turn dates.
I do the whole truck, I didn't care.
And so I did two trucks like this,
and I had a couple hundred dollars on me.
But now how do I spend
this money to get home.
I mean, I'm still walking
with nothing around, right.
And so, all of a sudden
this (mimics tire screech)
Corvette pulls past me and
turns around and he comes by.
Brand new Corvette, pulls
over and whips his door open.
"what you doing out here?"
I said, "Trying to get out of here".
And he says, "Where do you need to go?"
And I say, "Los Angeles".
And he says, "Oh, okay."
And he says, "I'll take
you to the bus station."
And I say, "Where are you goin'?"
He says to the courthouse.
I say, "You a police?"
"No darlin', I'm not a police."
I say, "You an attorney?"
He goes, "No, I'm an honorable"
I go, "Oh your honor!"
- [Mark] He's a judge?
So he takes me, he doesn't date me.
He takes me to the greyhound station,
he gets me a ticket, and he gives me $200.
And he tells me, "Get outta here,
this is not the place for you."
I said "Thank you very much."
You know, and so I get on the bus,
I got back there with like 470 bucks.
- [Mark] (laughs)
- [Reilly] My clothes
smelled like manure (laughs).
- [Mark] But you survived.
- [Reilly] I was so lucky,
I don't know, I mean I
could've just woken up
talking to Saint Peter.
I was lucky that I woke up at all
You know, but I remember looking
over and seeing this man,
all I could see was
Texas Chainsaw Massacre.
That's all I could think of was
Texas Chainsaw Massacre this guy was...
- [Mark] So you've had
more then your share
of these kid of run-ins.
- [Reilly] I don't per-se
now have that many of them,
because I go with my,
I'm empathic and I've realized this,
I go with my instinct.
If something says...
There's 24 hours before I
can get into somebody's car,
if my instinct gut says don't do it,
24 hours has to pass before I-
I might be wrong, but I might be right.
Who knows.
I don't do the "I knew I
shouldn't have" so much anymore,
because I listen to my gut.
You know it's just the,
that's just what's kept me alive so long,
is that I'll get into a
car and see these buttons,
and I'll go oh these buttons are really...
And I'll just keep like,
testing all these buttons
and I'll go (gasps) oh, its my instinct.
I just don't know, they
try to tell me something
but I don't know how to read it
so I just know I need
to get out of the car.
And they'll say "Oh
no...come back in 24 hours"
then we'll rejudge this whole situation.
But I've allowed myself
24 hours has to pass,
I can't get talked in.
'Cause let me tell you, serial killers
and serial rapists, they are charming.
They're charming, and they're well kept,
and they have a good personality,
and they look nice and smell nice.
They don't look like the
troll under the bridge
or you wouldn't get into the car.
- [Mark] Well Reilly, thank
you so much for sharing this,
another incredible story.
- Ciao.
(laughs) 'Till next time.
- [Reilly] We'll have
to do his story one day.
- [Mark] I don't have
any stories like that.
- [Reilly] You have to have something.
- [Mark] I probably
do, I just forget them.
- [Reilly] Everybody
has a story, see yeah.
I think you should do some hypnosis.
Lets do Mark on hypnosis.
Next time we meet, on
the Mark Show (laughs).
Thank you.
- Bye.